britain's secret intelligence service
mi6 has always been shrouded in mystery
for decades the chief was only known by
the letter c
and until 1994 the secret service
officially didn't exist
but mi6 is stepping out of the shadows
to stay secret we're going to have to
become more open
richard moore the current chief of mi6
is the first c to publicly use social
media
in one of his first ever interviews he
speaks to the economist asks podcast
about the biggest threats facing the
world today
from a possible russian invasion of
ukraine to china's growing capability to
access private data around the world
richard moore welcome to the economist
asks well it's very nice to be here
thank you for inviting me also in the
studio is shashank joshi he's the
economist defense editor shashank good
to have you here too it's great to be
here thanks what we've been watching
most closely in the last couple of weeks
has been this staggering military build
up on the edges of ukraine and watching
with growing concern i think there's
there's very important questions as to
russian intentions what is putin up to
uh very simply will he invade i think
vladimir putin does think in terms of
spheres of influence i mean very clearly
and he articulated that in his in his
public language
um he he really does think that russia
in the 21st century has the right to
sort of impose
limits on the sovereignty of the of the
countries on its periphery and and
that's a problem because uh those
countries are not going to accept that
and of course you know from our
perspective the uk and other and our
allies neither are we i mean you can't
um say that's fine uh mr putin
you get to choose what the people of
ukraine
get to decide you know to do with their
with their state it's not
it's just not possible so we do have
this sort of rather chronic clash of
ideas and ideology around this issue
it's really important that we're we're
very clear in our communicating uh to mr
putin about the you know the price that
would be paid if he were to push ahead
with that i mean i i hope he won't i
think
uh the ukraine has moved on since
uh 2014 i think they would
they are more able um to resist
um and um clearly the sort of economic
and financial price would be huge for
you know for a russian people that's
already suffering from a raft of
sanctions from 2014. let's turn to the
big challenges that you addressed in a
speech
in london recently and you said in the
first speech you've given us head of mi6
indeed that the greatest single priority
for the service is to adapt to the rise
of china it seems like quite a zigzag
from a few years ago when the messaging
seemed to be china is a great trading
investment partner and that we should be
open to china again what has changed or
do have you just reached a different
judgment
it goes back to why i gave a speech i i
wanted to explain uh a bit about what
the service is doing and uh the fact is
that um
the work we're doing on on china is now
the most important work that we are
doing and it is it's not that the work
we do on russia and
international terrorism is is any less
important than it was it's just that the
prominence and the need to understand
china
has grown because
china's influence and place in the world
has grown
but i said very clearly in the speech
that i thought we needed um to have a
positive agenda with china that we
needed to trade with china and that we
needed uh their cooperation on the key
transnational issues climate change uh
biodiversity at the end of the day
climate change is the biggest issue of
all
so you know i was advocating the need to
cooperate with china on that but at the
same time i was very clear that where um
china
because it is
a government which is an authoritarian
government with very different values
from our own where
it pursues its interests and its value
systems in ways which clash with our own
it's quite important that we are robust
in standing up for those values and
interests and in particular
as the integrated review set out
the key
sort of battleground if you like is
around technology do we
compete effectively with the chinese in
the really big technologies of the 21st
century
i think what's really interesting about
that is when we think of russia as an
intelligence challenge we think of
novichok in salisbury we think of
subversion across europe sort of
paramilitary um destruction
when we think of china it's very
different but our understanding is still
evolving you know i think people
instinctively understand the debate over
huawei that is control of
telecommunications gear can give a
foreign country a foreign agency access
to data i think what we're yet to fully
understand or debate
is things that seem less directly
involved in the security space that is
chinese access to data around ride
sharing apps dating apps genetic testing
kits biometric data
i think you hinted at some of this in
your speech richard talking about a
global surveillance web and how it
affects the states that are buying this
stuff from the chinese but also how it
affects your agents and officers and
their ability to go about their work the
data trap that i was trying to
articulate is much more difficult to
define isn't it
and but it is the issue that we had the
great debate around huawei in this
country it's just that overseas i think
that that level of understanding of
these issues is not as high as it is
here and it and it and it needs to be
because over time if you allow access
into key data
then then you will slowly erode your
sovereignty and of course
china china is looking for this
these data streams because
the greater amount of data you get but
also critically the amount of diversity
of data you get from around the globe
the better your ability to build the
artificial intelligence systems of the
future
thanks for watching you can listen to
the full interview on our podcast the
economist asks click the link to find
the episode and don't forget to
subscribe